(laughing)
- So, this was so much fun.
- Yeah, I had such a great time.
It was great.
And, I'll text ya.
- Yeah?
- [Guy] Yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah, will do.
Alright.
- See ya.
- Aww, you're leaving.
- Yeah, I gotta get ready for work, but,
maybe we can get lunch sometime soon?
- Yeah, that'd be good.
- I'm a big cannoli fan.
- Alright, let's do it.
Let's plan a menu around this.
I'm having a really good time.
- Me too.
(upbeat funk music)
(ominous music)
- [Female] Something's happening.
- I'm thinking...
Fettucine Alfredo?
(ominous music)
- [Redhead] I can't explain it.
- [Voicemail] It's Ben, leave a message.
- I'm starting to worry.
Should I call the police?
- No, you're crazy.
I'm sure he's just busy.
- Look, we put this picture on Instagram
last night, and now he's gone from it.
How do you explain that?
- Maybe you just chose a bad filter?
(horror movie music)
- [Guy In Plaid Shirt] I thought
everything was going great.
Was it something I did?
Was it something about me?
- It's not just me?
I thought I was alone.
- Oh, it's been happening for years.
- This is the first ghoster.
- Oh my god.
- This must go back
further than we thought.
(screaming)
- Guys, guys, come look at this.
- Breaking news right
now, it's called Ghosting,
and it's a new affliction
sweeping the nation.
(sirens)
People in their 20s in
large cities have been
the primary targets.
- Oh my god.
- Ape, where were you this weekend?
Why didn't you return my calls?
- Oh, I was camping.
I thought I told you.
- You're not gonna like,
ghost on me, are you?
- No.
Of course not.
- Alright, let's take a picture for Snap.
Not again!
- Check this out, his
Facebook is deactivated.
- [Girl In Blue] Well
maybe he blocked you.
- Hey, he liked my status!
But he can't respond to my text?
- What am I supposed to do now?
Go to the movies alone?
I already bought the tickets!
- Nothing makes any sense!
- What do you mean she just vanished?
That's impossible.
- Look, I know what I saw.
Why won't you believe me?
- You're crazy!
(grunts)
- [Redhead] What if, this is
all happening because people
are afraid of commitment
and confrontation?
(wind whistling)
(wind chimes tinkling)
(screaming)
- You know, I've been on a
couple dates with this girl,
but I'm just not really feeling it.
- Oh god.
- What?
- No, no!
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
(screaming)
(high pitched beep)
(ominous music)
(creaking of door)
- That's the only
reasonable explanation why
she hasn't called me back.
- Yeah dude, you're probably right.
(creepy keyboard music)
(screeching of dry erase marker)